Street Fighter 6 has learned lessons
from the content Bear release of its
predecessor and offers a variety of
significant features and modes right out
of the gate it's a robust fighting game
that is a premier quality a return to
form for the franchise that welcomes
both new Fighters and seasoned Pros
3 fighter 6 splits his content into
three hubs fighting ground which most
closely emulates the classic Street
Fighter experience battle Hub where
players can congregate and challenge
each other to compete in tournaments and
World Tour which is a sprawling story
mode with an open world and RPG hooks
each gameplay format centers on the
classic Street Fighter style of 2D
fighting gameplay and that excellent
core experience is what drives
everything
mechanically Street Fighter 6 doesn't
fall far from previous games in the
series you have multiple normal attacks
special attacks super odds and movement
techniques specifically designed for
each of the roster's 18 characters what
distinguishes street fighter 6 from
previous iterations are the core
Universal mechanics shared by all
characters these Universal mechanics are
also where much of street fighters whose
gameplay depth is the drive system is
356's new Universal battle mechanic and
I'm amazed at how much it adds despite
being simple to grasp by pressing the
two medium attack buttons I can Parry an
attack using Drive power or with Drive
rush I can immediately Dash forward out
of it for a burst of speed that can
catch opponents off guard or introduce
new combo sequences
functionally players that are
experienced with three fighter 4's Focus
attack Dash cancel all kill against
Roman cancels will feel right at home by
pressing both heavy attacks I can
initiate a drive impact that can stagger
an opponent and leave them open ensuring
that overly defensive players can be
opened up if an opponent is backed into
a corner Landing this will make him
Bounce Off the Wall adding a variety of
other strategic considerations and
opportunities
Drive reversals meanwhile allow me to
block an attack and counter with a move
that while not very damaging will help
Escape tricky spots and finally
overdrive lets me power up special
attacks like the EX system of old
these aren't unlimited however as each
move uses up part of the drive gauge
just below the health bar and a fighter
can burn out which slows their movement
speed and makes certain offensive and
defensive moves inaccessible for a
period the Strategic implications of
this system cannot be overstayed as
these new tools do wonders for the
overall fighting drive impact in
particular can swing the tide of the
battle in an instant as catching an
unsuspecting opponent with one will
allow you to put a hurting on them
keeping these tools in front of your
mind is key to Victory and luckily it's
not an overwhelming amount to recall one
of the major criticisms leveled s355 was
the rigidity of battles with some going
so far as to call it turn based however
these new mechanics make stream fighter
6 feel more fluid
okay
no matter how simple Street Fighters can
seem novice players are going to feel
some trepidation when stepping into the
ring for the first time the game is
ready for you though as Capcom has
implemented a new modern control scheme
that makes controlling Fighters more
like Super Smash Bros than a traditional
Street Fighter this gives new players a
foundation from which to learn but that
growth does have a ceiling if you decide
to transition to the classic control
scheme players will need to learn the
manual input controls that have been
used since Street Fighter 2. the easiest
place to learn 356 either in modern or
classic Styles is in fighting ground
which is a traditional Street Fighter
experience this is where you'll find
familiar modes like arcade mode online
ranked and Casual matches and offline
versus modes this section's shining
feature however is its practice area
which houses some of the best in-game
tutorials the series has ever had
practice mode has the classic freeform
training mode fans expect but also holds
full tutorials for the game's core
systems as well as character guides and
combo trials for all 18 characters on
the roster these character guides are a
deep dive into what makes each fight a
tick as it explains not only their
special moves but also the best
situations in which to use them fighting
ground also lets you Tinker with in-game
commentators one of the more balihood
features of Street Fighter 6.
[Music]
while hearing tasty Steve and WWE Zelena
Vega in an official Street Fighter game
is super cool the excitement those
commentators generate during an actual
tournament isn't ever captured here
those experiences are fueled by genuine
off-the-cuff reactions to the action on
the screen and in the arena while those
same voices sound like they're reading
situations from a script here which of
course is exactly what they are doing
Thrills to get around their defense if
you're looking for a less traditional
Street Fighter experience then what's
offered in fighting ground it's time to
take a world tour this is a massive
story mode with multiple chapters that
unfolds across the entire world the main
Hub is Metro city of final fight Fame
and it's stuffed with things to do and
references for long-time Capcom fighting
fans to find the rest of the mode is
broken up into smaller locations based
on stages from the core game these are
one of locales you'll visit sparingly so
they're not as big as Metro City but
they all still have a charm to them the
story being told in World Tour doesn't
live up to the standards set by fighting
games like Tekken 7 and more combat 11.
however everything happening around the
story makes up for in a big way walto is
essentially a street fighter RPG where
the fighting mechanics serve as the
battle system and it is very silly fun
walking through the streets of Metro
City I can challenge virtually anyone I
want to a fight be they a food truck
attendant an old lady going to the store
or a young Troublemaker getting up to no
good with every victory in my avatar
gains experience and levels up both
their core stats and the fighting styles
I'm using at the time this challenge
anyone mechanic is also technically
impressive as it really does let players
challenge anyone the game seamlessly
goes from challenging a passerby into a
fight and then returning to the free
realm without loading the stage is
whatever we were standing in front of at
that moment there is a noticeable dip in
frame rate when fighting in World Tour
and the visual quality of the stages and
random Fighters is nowhere near as good
looking as Ryu fighting Ken on a
carefully crafted stage but I didn't
focus on them much as I was too busy
enjoying the silliness of fighting every
Metro City Denizen that passed me by or
using money to buy a hat that somehow
improves my kicking power leveling up
fighting styles is the other major
customization option and growth path
your Avatar's move set is in your hands
and as you progress through the story of
Walter you meet the 18 masters of the
world aka the playable roster of Street
Fighter characters after earning their
respect through Mission completion or
even a one-on-one fight your avatar will
be enrolled as a student and given
access to that character's moveset
you'll pick a core move set for normals
but then you can pick and choose which
special moves you want your character to
use at one point my avatar used DJ's
rolling sober Blanca's Blanca ball
chunley spinning bird kick and Ken
troyukin that versatility and ability to
create your own fighter down to the
moveset is something new for the
franchise and a core part of what makes
World Tour fun using a fight stick to
control the Avatar in this mode is rough
the camera controls do not translate to
a controller with only one stick so
getting around the city can be
cumbersome the game does offer a
solution though it's not an elegant one
you can activate your fight stick as
Player 1 and your controller as player 2
and then switch between the two
depending on if you're moving around
Metro City or fighting someone while
this does mean extra space is needed for
two controls at once I appreciate the
convenience of easily switching every
time I want to use it your avatar also
takes center stage in the battle Hub
which is the final section of Street
Fighter 6's experience this is basically
a middle ground between World Tour and
fighting ground where players bring
their avatars into a massive Dome lined
with arcade cabinets you can sit down at
a cabinet and wait for a challenger
while training or you can join a queue
of players already seated the digital
equivalent of putting a quarter down on
a machine through fighter 6 netcode
sings no matter who I'm fighting or
incredibly which server I'm logged into
I made sure to log into the North
America South America and Asia servers
during my review time and nearly every
match I played in all three felt like my
opponent was sitting in the room next to
me that's not to say it's perfect as
personal internet connections are also a
major factor in performance but the
Advent of rollback netcode has been a
major Boon to the entire fighting game
genre and FIFA is the latest beneficiary
I had a couple of matches in the North
America region that did have some
netcode issues but my online play
experience as a whole has been
overwhelmingly positive fighting games
in the Modern Age live on through their
extra content and 356 is no exception
Capcom has not only confirmed the first
four characters coming via downloadable
content but much like 355 the game will
feature its own economy complete with
multiple currencies Drive tickets are
earned in game and fighter coins can be
earned in-game or purchased separately
as well as this there's a battle pass
which will offer Avatar gear emotes and
other perks in both a free and premium
track given how strong the base game is
having more content and being able to
play the game in different ways is an
exciting prospect I can't get enough of
356 it's been my last thought when I go
to bed and my first thought when I wake
up in the morning it has a beautifully
constructed fighting system but also
offers modes that take the game very
seriously and in other cases not
seriously at all there are some small
issues with performance in World Tour
but none of those are enough to derail
the overall package with the releases of
new Tekken and Mortal Kombat games it
very much feels like we're in a new
golden era for the fighting game genre
thankfully Street Fighter 6 steps into
the arena looking good and fighting fit
again
[Music]